mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée merci de votre question qui
vient prolonger celles qui ont été
posées avant mon arrivée et auquel a
répondu mon collègue Olivier bêche la
France va continuer d'exporter des
céréales à l'intention des pays tiers
elle va le faire y compris à part après
le 25 avril pour une raison simple la
première c'est qu'elle le fait dans le
cadre du droit et du droit européen qui
permet sur ce type de démarche de
déroger
à l'interdiction qui est fait d'utiliser
ce tel produit je rappelle en août que
la France va le faire à la demande des
pays d'import puisque c'est parce que
ces pays d'importation réclament cette
molécule que nous la mettons sur les
céréales et donc on va le faire dans ce
cadre là le droit la demande des pays
d'import elle va le faire aussi au nom
de la vocation exportatrice qui est
celle de notre pays vous l'avez rappelé
madame elle va le faire aussi au nom de
l'exigence qui est la nôtre de faire en
sorte que la sécurité sanitaire la
sécurité alimentaire et la souveraineté
alimentaire puisse exister en Europe et
dans le monde elle va le faire enfin
parce que l'Allemagne le fait pour
l'Algérie la Bulgarie le fait pour
l'Algérie la Roumanie l'a fait pour la
Côte d'Ivoire il n'y a aucune raison que
nous dérogions à ce que font d'autres
pays européens dans leur démarche
d'expert donc madame la députée pour
répondre à votre question et à votre
inquiétude qui peut paraître légitime la
France va bien continuer à exporter des
céréales dans le cadre réglementaire et
avec un seul souci à la vérité celui de
répondre à l'exigence des pays
d'importation qui est celle de trouver
sur le marché mondial des produits de
céréales qui leur permettent de couvrir
leurs besoins alimentaires